hi i'm ryan right and i'm gerry and i'm
michelle cute welcome two reasons to see
where we give you reasons to see and not
to see star trek into darkness warp
speed ahead reason to see number one the
action there's a lot of [ __ ] action
in this movie there was some action it
starts off with action practically ends
with action it's just non-stop action it
gives you a lot of energy like I didn't
feel like this movie was non-stop action
and the sense of like it's just one long
fight scene but like there are a lot of
really cool different types of fights
and stuff like that and more from me it
was like the urgency was up the whole
movie I felt they could have dialed it
back just a little bit and have that
classic scene we're not gonna make it
and in turn their ship sideways and yeah
and they make it and that's an every
good science fiction come isn't it what
we're gonna make we're not gonna make it
with our ship and they go through a
little crack here now yeah they've kind
of like transformed Star Trek more into
like the modern era and made it a little
bit less nerdy I love star chick I've
been watching star chick like since a
little kid with my dad like all of the
shows i guess like it's more like
inflict sci-fi in the intellectual sets
and then in the JJ abrams um like reboot
he's made he's brought that intellectual
aspect of the show like the nerdy aspect
but also mix it in with action so that
appeals to more people so now being into
Star Trek kind of mix is like a cool
thing you know this is refreshed reason
to see number two Benedict Cumberbatch
there the cucumber's amazing in this
movie man yeah sure he's a scene stealer
for sure he has this incredible ability
to be threatening same time has moments
where you get this guy like you
both eyes for him yes you think you do
yeah we always kind of just telling the
truth a lot of the time at least his
version of the truth but that's what
they say it's like what makes a great
villain is that they believe what
they're doing is in the thing to do it's
like they believe they're right they
don't know that they're they don't think
of themselves as evil you know you can
get someone who's way too threatening or
someone who's way too like intellectual
and he manages to bring those two
aspects together very well his voice is
very his voice is deeper than you think
it would be looking at his face oh yeah
and like the first thing I thought when
you started talking was I didn't realize
how deep Benedict Cumberbatch's voices
reason is he number three Captain Kirk I
love this actor I know I haven't I don't
know any other movies have seen you in
him but I really do like Chris I I love
Chris Pine a lot I think he's [ __ ]
awesome he's hot he's charming as ever
he's one of those guys that you see is
like yep he's a good looking
[ __ ] yeah a second yeah he has
okay with this guy he knows how to
command the screen to I mean it that I
think when it came to his scenes with a
Benedict cucumber he really allowed him
to take over the scene he seems like a
leading actor who's not afraid to share
the screen at all yeah right he knows
how to really lead a cast very well hey
cooperating he's funny too he's really
funny he's funny but I also really just
like what they did with his character
he's constantly conflicted and meeting
resistance and they really make Captain
Kirk like the theme of the movie
whatever Kirk has to go through yeah you
know you have that whole would you don't
know how to follow the rules you know
you're a rebel and we don't like rebels
but you know of course there's always
something in the rebel that makes him
the exception no reason to see number
for Spock dude man Zachary Quinto they
give him a lot more to do in this one
yeah and it's like they let him run the
show at one point you know yeah they
really played up the Spock Kirk
relationship hell yeah and also they
brought a little more into Spock as a
character and stuff like that
they brought like a bromance into it but
it was like it was like a trouble breath
it's like trying to work through it you
know trying to figure out where that
spark is again yeah exactly exactly some
people are getting upset about how much
they're exploring his human side which I
kind of get because what makes what made
Spock so cool was he's half Vulcan and
so you get to explore the Vulcan side
because because that's what you want to
see because he's a Vulcan we got to
explore the Vulcan side for how many
[ __ ] years now it's it let's explore
his human side and I'm totally on board
for that because it's such a repressed
side of him it's his most fascinating
side of my opinion because his Vulcan
side always shines it's it's constantly
there he's way more Vulcan than he is
human because most of the time he
behaves like a Vulcan yeah he believes
himself to mainly be Vulcan he doesn't
really acknowledge his human side to
begin with so when you explore his human
side and I did like how they linked it
back to the first one like hey my planet
was blown up and that's why I'm the
tatra my emotions yeah cuz you don't
want to argue with him on it yeah I get
it have you lost a plan yeah all right
chillum idolize it all of mine and our
home world I think I'm entitled to this
saw like a town was destroyed my planet
who is obliterate you guys lost your
archives I lost my entire world what do
you know about pain exactly wait to see
number five the humor something that I
really liked about this movie is that
they maintain that humor that was in the
first one it was such a nice thing to
see because that's what made the first
Star Trek so like whimsical and
uplifting and I like that they kept that
I didn't find it as funny as the first
it wasn't you're absolutely yeah I
thought yes called star chick in a
darkness and I do think he goes in a
much darker terrain than it does then
the first one did and so I think that's
why the humor wasn't as present I think
the third Star Trek is gonna be called
star trek into light heartedness but as
it stands there was a lot of stuff I was
chuckling at and there was a lot of
stuff that I was like smiling about
because I was just having a good time
and the characters you don't say what
you will about like depth and whatnot
but like all the characters had person
audi and they were all just they were
just all making me laugh at some point
you know Scotty's really fun and bones
is fun and you know Captain Kirk's got
his sort of you know Captain Kirk II
sarcastic ness and even just situational
many Steven Spock is funny yeah
everybody gets their moment we finna see
number six visual effects that's why the
the the one thing I think everyone's
gonna agree on with this phone yeah they
are fantastic I saw this on imax 3d and
they shot 30 minutes of this is actual
IMAX cameras and for those for those of
you who don't know why that's
exceptional who is because most movies
that play on imax screens it only takes
it like the center of the screen this
one takes up the whole [ __ ] screen
and it has the best quality you'll ever
see it was beautiful look at but i can
probably guarantee that even if it
wasn't our imax it would still look
amazing i did not see it on imax and it
still looked amazing oh there you go and
it was just beautiful it was such a
treat to watch reason to see number 7
production design love like just the
landscape of everything just the
attention to detail and almost every
single shot you know whenever they go
through like Starfleet or just the
cities are in you know like you get all
the London and daddy whatever whatever
whatever looks really doable and like
San Francisco and what every year
there's anything just Nibiru like the
planets there on or whenever they go
through Starfleet and you see all this
crazy detail in the background of all
these different types of ships and what
not even though things like you know
technology like their guns and torpedoes
all that stuff it's really cool then the
costumes are awesome like and the makeup
all of it was great i love the look of
the new Klingons it's got a flare it you
know it looks like it's got our lens
flare reason to see number 8 Scotty they
gave him more to do and he delivered on
what they gave him to do well and the
thing about simon pegg that I love you
know he's really funny but also he can
play really dramatic moments and he
could be very heartfelt and they utilize
all of his a lot of his different skill
he knows how to bring down right amount
of balance so that way it's believable
it out that way it's not like you're
just watching a comedian on screen
you're
she's somebody who's a human being who
happens to be really funny they really
show why he is an essential part to the
crew yeah definitely raisina see number
nine cinematography they have some crazy
angles in there like some great oh yeah
you know there's some crazy moments
where although just be like zooming in
but then turning into a Dutch angle and
while they're serving in it and
sometimes I thought the camera was a
little over the place was kind of hard
for me to tell what's going on for the
most part yeah there's some incredible
cinematography in here I didn't ever
think there was a moment where I
couldn't understand what was going on
visually you know I really liked just a
composition of the shots though the flow
of everything the look every shot is
like an awesome thing yeah it's like
even if they're just in the hull of a
ship it's like but this is really cool
looking yeah because it does have a very
signature look do it reason to see
number 10 the music yeah that's an i
found myself thinking part way through
this movie is like this is really cool
score so there's a lot of cool sounds
and dynamics and stuff like that what
makes a make some movies work so well is
you take all these different categories
and you turn them into like synergy and
music is such an essential part but if
we don't really look at all these other
things and music is what helps really
omit that emotion to the audience and
yeah I think a session where you're
seeing just a series of images in front
of you and music helps make all that a
much more much more smooth much more
fluid yeah and the music and this really
does help amplify the experience well
its got like a throwback equality at
times you know it's it's just really
interesting to listen to and especially
that combined with just the other sound
effect yeah like it really makes the
experience he of complete briefing not
to see number one rushed ending yeah and
it's only feels a little bit less then
that would be my one complain about this
movie if anything is like
reasons not the same number two
unaddressed plot points the one plot
point that really just stands out to me
[ __ ] decision number one ineffective
drama okay like I know you said a ton of
great things about this phone but
honestly from watching it I just
remember not being as pulled in as I
felt I should have been I was finding
myself getting distracted by a lot of
things and just never really feeling the
human complexity of it all going on I
couldn't feel a lot of the drama going
on it just seemed to be more about
adventure and the thrills rather than
actually having more of a captivating
story being told I felt like the outline
and the idea of the drama was really
good I just felt the emotional impact
wasn't there I don't know man I got
infected by pretty much everything in
this movie I thought they did a good job
I mean I was invested in it i was with
it i bought the jeopardy i bought the
peril like any moment I was like it's
gonna be okay everything's gonna be
alright yeah I can see why you would
feel I don't know exactly why I was so
pulled into this particular movie but it
was you know the way it sounded going in
it was gonna be like oh there's like ten
problems at once and it just seemed like
one big problem that kept escalating
like it would I say I did feel like it
was like the 10 big problems at once and
I guess the reason for the ineffective
drama would have to be because of our
second split decision oh dang split
decision number two lacks character
exploration this was my biggest
disappointment I felt like we didn't get
to explore all of the characters while
in the first one we got a sense of each
and every one of the characters yeah you
really like them you got to know them
and you're like all their an ensemble
they're great big baily work together so
great and this one there was a lot of
uneven screen time a lot of uneven
attention to each of them and that kind
of discipline yeah for me this film
scene way more about just the adventure
and just the escalating thrills and the
escalating danger but part of what made
part 1 so effective to me was each
character has their own unique
personality
they really each character felt very
three-dimensional this one part no I
don't like to do I felt like it was more
caricatures of everyone rather than them
all feeling like a true ensemble again
it didn't feel like we're hanging out
with these guys again or getting to
explore them more it was like yeah we
already established who they were in the
first one now let's make it about the
adventure and the only ones i felt like
it really got to explore what Kirk and
Spock you don't really get to get the
full grasp of everyone in the full sense
of fun and dynamics of this whole cast
coming together as I felt with the first
one I felt they kind of pushed all that
to the side like with the doctor they're
like this is making a funny guy that was
it like it was just a funny guy where is
in part one he was he was really a much
more of a not a number two in the way
how Spock was but much more clothes with
Kirk but just with a whole cast in
general there was just something there
that was missing which didn't make the
drama as effective to me because I
didn't I felt like if you didn't see the
first one you probably won't give two
shits yeah why'd you do cuz I you see
them as on the ship and it's like oh soo
do this Oh her your chance at okay cool
um yeah rushing is like okay like I
don't give a [ __ ] about that was
everyone doing their job doing their
adventure but not really getting to
explore these guys yeah okay so
everything you guys said but the
opposite of that experience I had with
this was like I don't know I really like
them as an ensemble I thought everybody
had several moments where I was like oh
yeah you know bones aah chak all you
know scummy my mates that was the issue
it was moment oh no be honest Francis no
I'm same time I'm say that these moments
come and go but they don't stay there
resonating throughout that resonated for
me like I always thought of them as an
ensemble even though it does yeah it is
more about the adventure than getting to
know the characters I'll give you that
which isn't a problem for me because I
feel like we got to know them and now we
know them and things are gonna change in
their dynamics but you know I liked what
they gave me I thought it was a great
ensemble I thought everybody you don't
had just as much personality
everyone was important and you know I
really liked all the characters this
time around look enough first one you
explore the characters and have great
adventure you have great drama they
could have done that in this second
movie and they did it and that was
disappointing is because it could they
could have done it and they did it this
one they did everything sergeant one has
but they cut back significantly on
character I I disagree with you I don't
know what else to say he like I'm is
you're not you're not agreeing with us
and that's what's getting much I don't
realize that type of a character study
like you know that's why people love it
because I don't want Star Trek because
it yes I realize this is supposed to be
there will be blood like women's what
makes Star Wars stand makes our stand
out is the characters who make Star Trek
so unique is the carriage nice it's not
just about adventure and space it's now
about it doesn't have to be this great
character study the first one is in this
huge character study either but at the
end of the day they offer they all felt
way more three-dimensional than they did
in this one okay well let me just say
this in the first movie and all the star
trek series the crew there an ensemble
they interact together it's not just oh
this dude toxic Kirk and this dude toxic
ER and this dude talk to Kurt and mr.
talk to Kurt but Delta X up watch it is
about everyone talking to each other and
interacting with each other Ryan's
consensus there are strong enough
reasons to see star trek into darkness
there are strong enough reasons to see
star trek into darkness the stuff that I
didn't really like about it i I really
don't agree with strongly which kind of
makes me go it was a disappointment but
when I look back on it I liked it a lot
more than when I first watched it series
consensus there are a lot of strong
reasons to go see star trek into
darkness there are a lot of strong
reasons to go see star trek into
darkness yeah man I had a great time
with this movie I I had a blast there
are a few you know hiccups here and
there but nothing that really detracted
that much for me Michelle's consensus
there a lot of good reasons to see star
trek into darkness there are a lot of
reason to Z star trek into darkness
despite the things that I was
disappointed about the movie all in all
I really enjoyed it I had a great time
watching it and I would definitely
recommend it to other people and I would
watch it again alright guys thanks for
checking out our show why don't you go
ahead scroll that comment box and tell
us what is your favorite Star Trek movie
just tell us which one you like if you
saw this you star trek tell us what you
thought about it did you love it hate it
leaving go into some of the spoilers and
piss off the other people who haven't
seen the movie yet who read your comment
oh and if you want to see more episodes
of reasons to see we got a little link
right down here so once you go ahead and
click it and if you want to see my
straight to the point review of star
trek into darkness if you want to know
what the difference is well you just got
to click that link right here and if you
want to get updated every time a new
review or videos out go ahead click on
Michelle people click that button
subscribe we want you to subscribe so
you can't even hang out with us every
week yeah punch it oh yeah warp speed
the subscribe button mm-hmm I can tell
you really wanted to say that would you
ever have sex with someone who had
Vulcan yours like Will Smith like real
Punk not he got his Vulcan your six he
has satellite years it's a really cool
scene when Boba Fett shows up in the
movie you cross over what if that ends
up happening because JJ is directing no
that would be cool doing all those
chambers movies yeah I would love to see
that I'd be tied I don't I would love to
see like Kurt and Luke's Luke Skywalker
there isn't even earth in Star Wars and
then you just could be across the
universe it's in the middle earth stuck
by then JJ Abrams will make Battlestar
Galactica the movie and we're gonna
cross them all over and then you know
what
you
you